I think lots of people are increasingly
concerned about what their evening for
very good reason particularly because of
all the food safety scares that we've
had in the last few years it's become a
much more immediate problem to a lot of
people I think a lot of people really
care about how animals are raised I
think a lot of people care that they're
not be pesticides on their vegetables
particularly on the pesticides that
they're feeding their children they
don't want artificial hormones being
given to cows and they don't want those
hormones and their kids milk these
issues are more and more coming into
public discussion and you can see the
evidence for public interest in that in
the rise in sales of organic products
which are just booming in the number of
farmers markets just booming in the
focus on locally grown foods also just
booming and so we're seeing the results
in the marketplace and believe food
companies know about
you